yo welcome to this video a new blitz
game and I'm in this viewer challenge
mode so i have to do something else
something that i don't usually do what
about the dutch okay i can go with g 6
ie6 i go e 6 here let's go for stonewall
absolutely not going to work here unless
he goes for g 3 anyway the early nights
III doesn't indicate that though
normally if they go early 93 they play
with III and Knight f3 Quincy to this
kind of thing or stuff like that which
looks that looks quite aggressive so I'm
going to take the pawn it's no other
option anyway so what about this like c5
that should be good I mean there are
those gambit yeah like the Staunton
gambit which I actually have played a
tournament chess to start and get but i
don't really know about having c4 in
here if this is so helpful and okay so
push d5 okay i'm taking funny funny game
here funny position so I wonder can I go
Isis crazy like a bishop d6 it's
probably really crazy look so why fight
if I just take the pawn that might
really give them compensation and with
hindsight I maybe shouldn't have taken
on d5
okay not sure taking it taking helps him
with the development really a lot so I'm
not sure if I want to grab the pond ok
so here I thought just g6 this is a
funky funky position it really looks
like the modern been only without the f
pawns which is really really crazy but
ok I'm interesting I think exactly if we
if we wouldn't have had F pawns this is
a completely normal position not sure
about GMP to be perfectly honest yeah my
light squeeze here those those are
definitely tricky but ok his dark
squares are also not exactly ideal ok so
he wants to go if five it seems let's do
this and take with the night I might
have a five him I can take the vision
takes king of sound I don't think this
is so big of a problem
maybe he five a b5 cheeks yeah he's
going for it all rights I don't know is
this so great I know where the king is
on f7 but it's got Knight f3 or what
Knight f3 mmm yeah I can also take with
the bishop on b5 it's not Knight takes a
B and with that that makes my dark
squares like completely busted yeah okay
I cannot do that actually
there should be five 95 85 cheeks their
King 37 hmm it's a bit crazy okay I'm
taking him check really not i'm really
not positive about this don't know so i
can go like age 60 on night g5 check is
wait it is a check but is it much more
you can castle this is more of a problem
quickly castle okay go age 6 wow yeah
that's what you get with the opening
challenge this is a challenge surviving
this this nonsensical position but it
wasn't really about them them and the
opening wasn't bad at all i think i was
doing very fine actually but I going
into this while there was a mistake Jim
should a five-night age for hmm in 95
sitting
I don't think nach five wins straight
away it might might but what I'm doing
here would be three is just confusion
tactics I'm trying to confuse them and
this really is really better you can
play I mean probably that's something
better but he can just go Bishop g2 c3
and 95 probably don't don't see how I'm
holding this wow that's amazingly bad
disposition we should change this
totally okay is going for peace
sacrifice direction this is probably
winning would be quite surprising if not
but was difficult to to avoid I guess
f7 King g7 he just needs okay f7 check i
can go to 2h7 okay yeah if a tick is 6
Queen takes I'm directly mated so that's
not up I have to move this I have to
move the Queen hmm okay can't you
sacrifice the Queen and some and some
meaningful way the worst is he can play
Knight f8 this is the worst problem f7
is probably also winning but night fa de
some is easiest cannot even recapture
wow it was bad
Mary the time warning this wasn't an
opening problem this was a bad play
problem check
yeah so Queen g7 made right um my
intention was to ok I can share that
anyway so it's not much else yeah he can
avoid the draw though I ask Bishop e3
even so yeah he should be 3 and this is
what what he's going to do ok so that
was a real disaster black resigns yeah
so let's go back there come on let's go
back I think I think this must be
actually really good for like I don't
believe in there at all playing with f3
and ce4 combined but I'm probably
starting to do stupid things around him
or is there something something better
than the same file it looks it looks
very logical though be sure before yeah
be sure before that makes a lot of sense
actually but c-54 Kim that's a moment
here and he took hmm yeah maybe yeah
this is this is too dangerous maybe this
is too dangerous 95
yeah so this is losing it is it is very
very tricky I wonder I wonder actually
if we see here this is what the engine
is suggesting yeah okay maybe check
maybe this kind of thing why does better
yeah of course but it's not not decisive
so the whole thing is already here is
yeah I'm busted so it was bad really and
something that I should have seen but
then this means I probably c5 is wrong
and I should I mean not wrong like
totally bad but this looks bad I am
getting this pin and it also increases
my development i can castle quickly yeah
if he takes i can't really just take
yeah this is not check leading leading
anywhere so that is better i am now c5
is usually quite a good idea to attack
the center when there is no Knight f3
easily available 92 but d5 is in fact is
quite quite good okay it was some kind
of a disaster but that was more bad play
by me than the opening itself okay well
thanks for watching